this is the scenario they give you
and they say find the gradient of the
tangent of the inverse function now
there's a couple of ways to approach
this
you can think oh i know how to find
inverse functions
i know how to find inverse functions all
i need to do is
switch the variables and then change the
subject
right so you think about that you're
like cool it's all right
no problems under control uh-oh
right so you can see this is probably
not going to be a helpful way now
read the question carefully
read the question carefully they don't
actually want the inverse function
all they want is the gradient of the
inverse function gradient
gradient how do we work out gradients
you differentiate now if i
differentiated this right
i would get d y on dx right
and then well i could work out what that
is but i don't want this gradient i want
the gradient
of the inverse right well just like
before
if i want an inverse all you have to do
is switch variables isn't that all it is
i've switched my y for an x and an x
for a y so if i can work out what this
is
all i have to do is take the reciprocal
that's all there is to it
so okay where's my working
okay so here we go
let's differentiate 2e to the 2x plus 3x
squared
yep so from that
i take it if that's the greeting
function of the original function
the gradient function of the inverse is
the reciprocal of that
see okay so now i want to know at a
particular value of x i think it's zero
isn't it
when x equals zero
so then all i have to do is sub it into
this which is the derivative of the
inverse
okay which is um let's see
uh a half